he's Brad like that bang in the
head
I don't give a you walk and I know
I know a lot of you like
yo you can't hit a woman he's a
nun big difference okay
[Applause]
just friends in the world we got to love
him he's awesome
there's the gentleman Joey Diaz I got a
three year old you know and I look at
that she's beautiful I look at it and
I'm like you know when she gets older I
don't think I have the heart to
smack at a discipline you don't saying
like low like a sneaker at the casting
time the time and like that when I
look at my daughter I don't have the
heart like I look like I had to probably
punish her and send it to a room but can
I hit it now like I don't say I
have the balls to do it but they all
suck they always say that if you grew up
in the house day you got up back
cuz you'll probably have a house that
you people up at you know like if
you haven't and I tell you what I grew
up in the 70s my mom me up okay
my mom's talked me up not like it
was a controlled beating okay let's get
this straight
everybody in this room got a controlled
beating at one time that means you're
not gonna and die okay you're gonna
take a couple punches to the head you'll
go down in two days you get a doll no
big deal that's a controlled
beat all right you're not gonna
die you know when I was a kid I used to
bust my mom's balls and you know she's
Cuban and a single mom and she would
lose a temper from time to time and you
know you get like my mom would hit me
like the straight punch to the head but
the overhead right and Spanish
is Goldeneye we own it means the
airplane and then they had to had like
different names on then they have like
the a guy a top so that's the
bitch-slap you know that's the Stockton
slap right and then my mom had the
backhand and stop I walk out that's just
to throw you off to open you yeah it
opens you up for a side kick to the body
right that's at that time
like ah Bob executive so I took a
beat listen my mom threw a beating on me
one time on 86th Street when I was like
6 I wouldn't get off a mule in front of
8 there's a bank on 86th and Broadway
and there was a mule some dude
with a mule and you get my $3 and he put
a cowboy hat on here and let you get on
the meal with a fat bitch and I
wouldn't get off the mule my mother beat
the out of me with the first that
was a good one not gonna live the
parents kite beat you don't get those
but that was it like as I got old I
never really got hit and my mom was
singing on my homily statement don't
ever let nobody touch your face a real
man doesn't let nobody touch their face
don't let nobody touch your face
so being Cuban I was also Catholic so my
mom would scare me with the nut and she
goes you up I'm gonna send you to
school those nuns will you up well
have to torture my mom for you she said
it I'm putting you in Catholic
school I like the nuns deal with you and
I think my mom knew the nuns are gonna
me up she just didn't want to know
you know I'm saying like she's like
they're gonna you up but I don't
want to know about it so it was one of
those schools Sacred Heart School for
Boys you went on Sunday and you came
home on Thursdays and the nuns will
complete douche bags I mean
completely respect you and I'm not like
I don't give a if you don't like
the truth they were I think
about it now 30 years later and it
really was mild abuse it was very mom I
could have gone my won-won on those
bitches but you know nobody would have
listened to my cries understand me they
say nuns don't whatever so there was
just one nun sister Anna there was just
a Marie that was just a heissen and
there was just to have some of them
sister Patricia sister heissen
was the most evil person that ever
walked the face of the earth
they didn't hit me at that school
because I was a bad person they used to
hit me because I didn't like milk till
this day listen till this day I
hate milk okay
I'm not allergic to it I just don't
like it that's it a milkshake
completely different I'll drink
senator
but milk laying out of a bottle like
that
it smells like dick I don't like
that's it I never like it I
don't like broccoli then I don't like
his mouth I don't give a I don't
like it but they would abuse me if I
didn't drink the milk they put it on my
head and then bitch slapped me like
three times and then when I went
down she hit me with the tray a few food
these people Savage
and this one nun sister - she's
New Jersey she looked just like Governor
Christie all up he was like five
foot two three tens the bitch didn't
around and if you look at a nerd
they have a ring of Jesus
they're married to Jesus and before she
hit you she'd turn it around and that's
how they cut she and like
that
dumb these sons don't around guys
this is real old-school
Catholicism and no no I wasn't molested
I was an ugly kid that is with me
and I'm back you I wasn't off the
board but I never hung out you I
don't want to play cause I don't want no
hard ice cream
I'm a cargo anyway I'm saying
I'm a car down bump that
hard ice cream bitch you think
you're dealing with I got more low you
know bang so I'm in the 5th
grade I've been there for like three
years not in the fifth grade I
had access to school for three
years I thought in the dirt braids and I
stayed there to the fifth but there was
a reason why I didn't know I didn't know
if I was like dirty I wanted I wanted to
make my confirmation I'm like why am i
making my confirmation at 30 and I
remembered this story this is why
because in the fifth grade I couldn't
take it no more that my dad died when I
was three so my parent my mom at the
time put me in kungfu like karate with
the brothers these black
on 90th Street and they would teach you
like ghetto karate like judo and
I was out of my mind between that
and Bruce Lee I was ready to kill the
young man and Bruce Lee had
died that I was all up in the
head my dad had died and between the
pain and the low self-esteem and
the anger I was boiling inside one day
I'm in the Catholic school
there's two little twins I like at
Momo's Raphael and Nino and I'm saying
they're crying I'm like why you
cryin for little sister Isis my mommy's
having a baby and since Isis won't let
us call the hospital you know that's for
nothing
Jesus don't pay for these lights
your mom and dad do get up just go pour
your mom it's an emergency in
the nuns just the high standards and she
goes really all three is go outside and
wait now when the nun told you to wait
outside the class that means you would
get the beating like you're
getting the knocked all right so
the bell rings
the bell rings like you know she comes
out and she goes so what you three guys
what were you talking about
and there was a two twins she took the
one twin first smack the out of him
like 15 times he went down he went to
class me and I'm like I looked at the
twin I'm like that's your brother get in
there right why am i
fighting for you get in there you
she grabs him this world up and
then she grabbed me and started bitch
laughing me but I kept thinking about my
mom I got sick and tired his
hit me every time I
wouldn't drink my milk and I was about
to snap so I put my hands up and she's
biting her tongue enough forget this
going put your hands down put your hands
on like fluffy you got to work for it if
I'm saying I ain't putting down
she's hit me in the temple his
bitches me up so finally she
says you're not gonna put your hands
down getting the utility closet that's
basically where they killed you
right there they just killed you
then they called your mother and said he
died of pneumonia and that was this
creepy mother those Catholics
I'm telling you right now I look behind
the curtain that creepy so
she says getting a utility Clark that's
what I have like the books and the
protractors and all that so
we get in there and she doesn't
even slam the door guys she just
jacks me right in the mouth like
I thought my old fat I feel the blood
but I put my hands up and she's like
don't you have autonomy and she's just
smacking me god she's just going at it
damn man and she had elbows she had
cases way before UFC Unleashed this
bitch is going on she's kicking my legs
too low on my hand and she smacking me
I'll tell you what guys I you know I was
pissed I I couldn't believe this
lady was doing this to me and at one
point I'm I'm gonna take this
bitch out I'm just going to take this
out I don't give a but
if I go for it I gotta go for it
so she's 320 you follow me I'm like a
hundred with a crucifix in my pocket up
here
if I go for it I got to go for this
so finally she's like put your hands
down I wouldn't put him down but I
started tasting the blood in my mouth
and I started losing it and
something just made me go I'm gonna go
for this but I'm gonna grab
it by the ears and I grabbed it by the
veil because that's what the magic
powers alright
I grabbed her by the veil on my
goats never hit me again
you got up I hate you and I'm
just crying this is seven years of anger
and pain I miss my father what's going
on in my house I just grabbed I kept
banging a head I don't give a
you I'm I know I know a lot of
you like Joey you can't
hit a woman she's a nun big
difference okay -
different
he don't suck some pie they'll take it
in the end he's gonna angry right
they don't need no niggas walk
around with a black do not
something's gotta be done
it's up Kenny's up there
narrator the walking around like
somebody died yeah so
that's what I I gotta fight a it in
now when I let it go because I know
she's gonna my world up and I'm
pound and pound mm but a black dudes
they taught me judo too so I want to
give a like the hit bro but see 320 I
couldn't do it so I just settled on a
headlock and I'm rapping helped by the
head and I'm squeezed and she's
going you're gonna go to hell and I'm
like daughter you please don't
it you you and slimy
little man mafia kid thank God for
Italian people
thank God the accountancy then I
give up talk about the rules
what nothing this guy's like what's goin
on we tried to kill me it makes
this bitch pieces are honey quit I got a
headlock this wing you oh my god and we
don't give a nothing runs around
but hey what happened
now the goal is open there's a bunch of
kids and then young coach oh oh oh oh so
now I got a killer in Adamic say no
turning back so we take them out
of utility closet they're yelling call
the police I'm a koala Feliz I'm
bleed I don't give a Walla top with
twins are other kids coming over they
kick its butt corner regions do anyone
ever tell Roberto Clemente
hahahaha why don't know nothin I don't
know nothin I call the police the
kids that claps it's crazy
we're taking over the whole
hallway and I go it
let's call my mother so we drag this nun
and a half of arm bar and a headlock and
we took the shoes off I don't know why
till today
three other kids a big fat feet
with no nail polish and we took the
feet out from under I just dragged us
her head was turning red I wonder the
poor the Ricans call the number put it
to my head I phoned my mom me my mom hi
Mary oh that means the nun hit me let me
tell you some Kearny New Jersey it's
about 22 minutes from Union City New
Jersey my mother made it in eight
minutes
she show's over to eight for the Ricans
in the Santeria freaks with a live
chicken understand that's when six those
down so they finally got me
off the flock she's my head up
the veils off my mom tell me you want to
hit my son you got to get in the
ass and have your own cares artist I'm
loving it my mom got my back and so
now we're sitting down people holding on
to the heads that the priests in the
room the principal and they come my mom
he's out him and his other
cohorts like eight of us they're
out of here and my mom was listening to
play she's got half a bag on she's a
little drunk and shed and she's like I
ain't gonna nowhere and then
they're like no he's got to go he's out
of here then listen I was growing up
there was a Jew booking enable a
tremendous I'm Akay so I thank God for
Jewish people
all right this was a bookie
but in the early 70s if you beat him for
like two or three thousand he would show
up at your house with five dollar bills
and he say to you
you want me to pay you on paintable I'm
gonna give you five hundred I let it
roll till next week then the next week
he got you you follow me so he you had
is he always had your money he
which is why he said he had 500 dollar
bills who the is it was good five
dollar bill people would believe it
that's an old Jew trick like that let me
tell
hahahaha you know and you know
Larry he goes to throw my
mom out my mom goes listen he ain't
going nowhere or I want my deposit back
in five that's an old Jew trade - it
blew their mind five you don't have no
five so clumsy
then my son stays
okay and they let me graduate let me
finish out to you but you know what a
nun never hit me again that's my
story
[Applause]